i'd like to
welcome you along today the runanga in
nakiti
mataranga poonamu
and the committee today will deliberate
the five submissions to the proposed
school district council class for
ntab policies which were held on the
12th of may
we had two presentations
one personally and one by zoom
in three written submissions
we have no apologies today and
present we have councillor
reed councillor heisted and her ceo
um steve parry and carla brotherston
will take our minutes
um do would you like to read any of the
background
to where we are just in the memo please
steve
thanks madam chair this has been
unfortunately a long and winding road
proceeded with the continuation of that
approach is the way forward
so the review was put out
way back in 2019 we eventually got to
get the
hearing of submissions in may this year
and now you have before you
the opportunity to deliver deliberate on
those submissions
uh i've provided a report madam chair
outlining
uh what are the the key issues that have
come before summits
but uh typical of this
issue and and consistent with the flavor
of previous reviews
you generally get two main schools of
thought
one is trying to restrict as much as
possible
the opportunities for um
creating problem gambling and therefore
trying to
see a meaningful reduction in gambling
opportunities
versus uh some other commentators or
submitters
that would prefer to see a relaxation of
the current policy settings
and therefore uh it's completely over to
the the committee
but i do wonder let him chair whether
you might want to
wrestle first with that philosophical
issue um
and if it can be resolved it may then
easily inform decisions on the specific
issues raised by submitters that i've
covered off in my report
thank you just before we go ahead
we'll just um ratify the minutes of the
12th of the fifth
would someone like to move they'd be
thank you so firstly then the panel will
debate the different philosophies of the
submissions
and whether we need to relax the policy
or make it more
restrictive which then will give us a
firm basis for
um forming our decisions
any comments yeah thanks
question to the chief executive is in
terms of
of restricted or liberal where do you
see the needle sitting on a current
policy i understand it's at the maximum
end in terms of
sinking what is that correct yes through
your madam chief yes that's correct
although there is a an allowance for
some relocation
of machines in terms
of in the event of a natural event like
flood or earthquake
and a close analysis of the act would
suggest that
it is a form of relocation albeit it's a
very
tightly restricted relocation um
and that could trigger and i think it
does trigger the need for social impact
assessment
so you might want to
if you really wanted to have a as
maximum
restrictive policy as possible you could
remove
that ability to relocate in the event of
a natural event
such as a flutter earthquake or fire
and that would obviate the need to
undertake a social impact assessment
i i guess madam chair my comment there
would be just
i think we need to have a realistic view
on likelihood
under those scenarios it's it's our
earthquake seems pretty remote and it's
probably the last of this district's
issues if we're facing uh
earthquake that's at that level of
destruction fire of course is probably
slightly different but yeah i think we
just need to be careful we don't throw
the baby out with a
bath water over something with such
remote light
but this might only be my personal
just through you madam chair um yeah i'm
not in favor of
to be quite honest on the relocation
because of natural events and and also
i think there's plenty of opportunity
for um
the machines that they currently have
there's a natural cap there isn't there
that
and i noticed that none of these
submitters well three of them
and probably are not are asking for a
continuation of our sinking lid policy
and i'm actually quite in favor of that
i think that works
to best benefit everybody so that would
be my
thoughts i yeah at this stage thank you
there is um there has been i think the
in their policy they said just a change
of wording you could change the wording
from reduce this is in 0.13
to no increase which would mean there
would be
84 machines in total
and no increase on that which would
then bring you back to the relocation
and having to have that
um social policy assessment done
if you did want to relocate
would that be a cat though rather than a
sinking lid
if the numbers and machines were yes
which could be in
a unintended consequence of following
that part
sinking lid in terms of needle i think
current policy is
is restrictive and
we need to be careful we don't it is yes
i know it can
having a cap could change that
i believe just to assist the
committee madam chair um the sinking lid
on on its own it looks kind of severe
but in reality it's not as severe
because there are strong existing use
rights for
machines that were lawfully in place in
2001 before the act came into place
they were allowed to continue to operate
and therefore
despite having a sinking led policy for
the last
half dozen years there hasn't really
been any meaningful
change the number of machines
yeah i think actually i think there's
been one since 2013
one loss of one machine so that's
seven years in only one machine
so the panel would actually like
to keep um keep the restriction on
on them of having the sinking lid policy
and no relocation
if it's just a committee you might want
to just
land on a philosophy if you want to see
a tight restrictive policy in principle
and then you can work through the issues
and based on that
overarching philosophy the answers will
fall out of those categories
right so that is the question whether we
want to be
restrictive or less restrictive
i honestly think that our policy as it
stands
actually covers a lot of bases and you
know really do we need to make any
changes to it
yeah i agree under the restrictive
guys in reality i guess going forward
okay is that the answer
again if it helps a committee i don't
think you are
being invited to have a categorical
statement that covers
all basis for all issues raised by
submitters but if you say that and you
have said
that you want to see a continuation of
the current theme of being having quite
a restrictive policy
that then used as a touchstone for when
you go through
the different issues that are presented
by submitters
exactly so the first
discussion point is the ewe consultation
and um i believe that that was
that was a fair comment and that we have
gone to some lengths to address that
would you like to speak to that
yes uh madam chair i think again the
uh the comments of our local here we
are well made um but they do need to be
put in
a sense of some historical context um
they these the submission was made back
in september
uh we did not do justice to the
um engagement with ewe before we
came out of the blocks for the draft
policy um as i
openly admit in my commentary the policy
or at least in the hearing minutes the
policy was
driven more about legislative compliance
and we didn't quite get there anyway
and since this time we have had a lot
more discussion with
hakuni rananga we are at the advanced
phases of finalizing a chart of
understanding
where one of the cornerstone principles
enshrined in that document is a policy
of no surprise and early engagement so
i would envisage that moving forward any
further review would be
one of the first protocols would be to
confer with
hakoneranga and other allied ewe
interests
to develop a platform for
progressing any future review
thank you
the um the second point is the club
merges and whether
they should be allowed to happen
and whether they are merged to one
venue
and the reasons that they can be that
they can be merged
just referring to the policy it talks
about requiring ministerial approval
and having a limit of not more than nine
machines at any one venue
so to me that's quite fair
yeah i think the um submitter was
putting forward the view that a merger
constituted a relocation and should
therefore be the merger should be
compelled to put all
machines in one single premises but you
can have mergers
madam chair that retained individual
premises but share
a similar legal entity similar
executive committee maybe a
executive secretary or manager um
therefore
my view was that i didn't think it was
automatically
a relocation and that
would you really want to force clubs to
say you know you do this you must
actually put all the machines in one
one venue that to me seem to be a little
bit of a step too far but
that's committee's choice
come in the house look around
look around the country and just see the
the issue some of the rsas are facing
you know i know this is about the
gambling policy but they are a big part
of those
lifeblood of those organizations and
there may be situations where to survive
over time certain clubs all need to work
together
and i think there's a bigger community
benefit
counselor reeve do you have any thoughts
yeah i think um
given where we are in a small community
um
eventually i think there will be a maybe
there may
become a need for those um
social places to maybe merge um
and really the um
whether or not they would take those
machines i think they're
they're already pretty much covered
aren't they under what the
what our axe is now
yeah the through human chair the uh
currently if the machines that are in
the different premises
uh a lot if they've lawfully established
as at 17 october 2001
they have a right to exist yeah and if
clubs
merged um the
uh under the current proposal of your
current policy settings
they could continue to exist on their
premises um
they wouldn't be allowed to relocate
into a combined premises um
you you could permit that uh
but my understanding is the submitter
was more inclined to say
they shall and to me that was perhaps an
unreasonable interference with
an organization's affairs in terms of
whether it wants to run two premises or
on-premises
and even though those um
plays those venues may decide to merge
it doesn't mean to say
technically that there's the available
space to even have those extra machines
so
you know that that would be another
issue but
um i know that
some of our submitters would have liked
to have seen a strict prohibition
of those relocations and i think we've
already covered that that that's
as it stands now there's not a great
deal of ability for those people to do
that so
i think that's says it all
so the policy as it stands is
covers all of these bases and we're
happy with that
you spam chair uh save for the event
of a natural disaster fire
flood earthquake there's no relocation
allowed
so the social impact assessment
um a number of submitters have requested
that a social impact assessment of
gambling be undertaken
and under section 1025 b a territorial
authority must consider the social
impact of gambling
in high deprivation communities within
its district
and if it is considering whether to
include a relocation policy
just for you madam chair i think if um
if those
just for instance it was a local club
that was um
wanting that to happen i think if that's
the case they should pay for
those
legal things to be done those um
sorry i've lost my train of thought
there slightly
you know that
assist thank you very much for that
assessment to be done i think that that
should
um i don't see why our ratepayers should
have to pay for anything like that
um if you know their businesses and if
that's how they run their business and
make
income even though some of it is passed
back to the community i think that
the onus is on the personal opinion
council heisted yeah i do agree i'm just
wondering in terms of where we find
ourselves
with this review it's been quite
protracted with it whether there's an
opportunity
to invite pre pre the next review
and invite obviously engage with ewe but
also invite those parties that were
proposing that
whether they'd like to contribute to a
social impact report
before we sit down to do this review
that would seem more logical than than a
piecemeal approach that we we may find
ourselves following now
yes to be honest the
social impact assessment or the need for
it becomes somewhat redundant if you
retain your tight restrictive policy
because the act says that if you're
going to entertain relocation policy you
must do a social
impact assessment you've had submitters
have said well
we'd like you to to think about the
ability to relocate machines away from
low
socio-economic areas and obviously
this committee i don't think in all
conscience could allow that without
having some professional
advice about the impact of doing that
or any other type of moderation
of your relocation policy but as it
currently stands
save for the argument about around the
natural events or disasters that occur
that could wipe out a
gambling venue there are no relocations
allowed
and therefore i don't believe you need
to do a
social impact assessment so counselor
heist his comments are
very good but again if you are starting
your review
and you are inclined to carry on with
the the current policy settings
you probably wouldn't be inviting others
to
to contribute to a social impact
assessment because if you're not going
to actually
entertain expanding your relocation
ability in the policy my comments were
on the basis of
if the committee was of mine to
entertain
relaxing its relocation
perhaps the the beneficiaries of such a
policy should contribute either in part
or whole
to the cost of a professional social
impact assessment
but because you've resolved this issue
philosophically at the start
that you want to retain a tight policy
setting
it probably doesn't need to be um
fur but need to be further analyzed at
this point in time but council high
status has a good point
when you go to your next review and you
start to figure out
are we in the mood for some revisions of
our policy settings
and if there are more an appetite for
some relax
relaxation then definitely asking
those that could benefit from such a
policy to contribute to a social impact
assessment would be a good
i think prudent move forward council
hosted
i also hope we're not being naive but
perhaps a little bit provocative
with a social economic sorry with the
social assistance of economic
system what on earth are we going to do
with that like effectively we've got a
pretty limited toolbox here to deal with
gambling
and it might be a great ideal but
i think the impact report is going to
reveal a whole lot of things that we
can't actually address through a simple
policy
you know online gaming gambling for
example doesn't
it's it's it's growing it's unrestricted
it's not even the new zealand heart
so i'm just fearful that that pathway
gives us a whole lot of problems but
probably an organization that's not in
any place to to deal with it
i think that's a good point yes it is a
good point you make
um so at this stage what we will
do is leave um leave a policy as
is but in a review then we would
look to um ask the community
and ewe to join in a review on
on forming a social policy if necessary
if we change the relocation
better cheer so uh you're not going to
be conducting a social impact assessment
at this point in time
but you i'm interpreting your
decision that if there is
a an appetite or mood at the next review
to
relax the relocation provisions that
you would you know that you would have
to conduct a social impact assessment
but you would be looking for the
beneficiaries of any relaxation
policy to contribute in whole or part to
that
um assessment thank you
okay sorry just to make sure that that
will take that next review
isn't it three years three years yeah
three membership yeah three three years
or earlier if the committee or council
so wishes
so um i agree with councillor reed about
the organisation paying for the social
impact assessment
so do we need to if there was one
required
do we need to write that into our
recommendation
i don't think so madam chair i think you
could just simply because bear in mind
the next review may
be conducted by yourselves or another
panel
i just think you could note that uh you
believe it's a meritorious
initiative or idea that if there is an
appetite in the future for
relaxing and relocation policy that the
beneficiaries of such a policy should
fund
the social impact assessment that will
be required
thank you
the next point raised by the submitters
was the sinking lid
versus the cap and we've had a little
bit of a discussion around that so
i think we have agreed on the sinking
lid the liquor licensing and gaming
policy there um
there was a submission to that um
that that these suggestions provided
audited accounts for the previous three
years
along with the details of income derived
from alcohol
food sales and gaming machines
would you like to speak to that please
yeah madam chair i conferred with our
senior regulatory officer mrs francis
shepard who's also a liquor licensing
inspector
on this matter and bear in mind that
liquor licenses are
considered under the sale and supply of
liquor at 2015
and there's a prescribed form for the
applicant to fill out
i don't believe it is
proper for the authority to impose
further requirements on the applicant
that are not required under the act and
indeed i believe it will actually set
the council up for
a judicial review for one of the classic
things of the judicial review is that
importing irrelevant considerations so
if the act doesn't require it
uh i don't believe it is within our
jurisdiction to demand something that
the act doesn't require
and hence my recommendation is that
despite
i can understand the the sentiments of
the submitter but in a pure
legal sense i don't believe we have the
authority to require it
thank you mr perry
um there was one other submission
regarding the length of time
allowed for submissions and i think you
have
answered that that the time frame can be
extended
if required
trust me madam chair though this this is
a an outlier in terms of how we've run
this process so
it will be a lot different next time
right thank you
that um that brings us to the end of our
debate today
and um since there's actually no
adjustments to the policy as such
um that'll be the end of our decision
making so we
um
we will um take this these decisions to
the full council meeting
for signing off and ratifying
that's correct madam chair so it'll um
based on these decisions you may want to
have a
an overall resolution that the draft
policy
is notified
be recommended for adoption
and then that policy will then go
forward to full council for approval
thank you can we use that wording
i'm happy to move there can you move
that second
thank you is there any other um
anything the panel would like to add or
no i'll close this meeting and thank you
thank you for attending